there has never been a leak from an
active terror organization on a scale
even remotely like this an unprecedented
cache of information that could destroy
Islamic states fighting infrastructure
tens of thousands of files names
addresses telephone numbers and
crucially the network that recruited
them Islamic state is suffering but this
for them is a potential disaster and
it's happening right now the files
pastor Sky News were obtained in Turkey
the country that has been the staging
post for the foreigners who make up the
elite Kandra of Islamic states fighting
force it's been the key to the terror
organizations success ideologically
driven jihadis programmed to follow
orders and commit acts of brutality to
divide communities and to take control
with blistering speed repeated
throughout history brutal repressive
regimes have an obsession with
bureaucracy to join up would be recruits
had to convince their sponsors of their
eligibility this form was crucial 23
questions names and addresses their
education the countries they've traveled
through on the way to Syria previous
jihadi experience and their phone number
contact at home I've got the work till
I'm dead and meet my dream a lot of the
names are well-known to us abdel bari a
26 year old from london entered in 2013
after visiting Libya Egypt and Turkey he
designated a fighter in the UK he was
better known as a rap artist
his whereabouts are unknown another
jihadi now dead after being hit by a
drone is Junaid Hussain the head of the
Islamic state media wing who plotted to
attack the UK with his wife former punk
rocker Sally Jones her whereabouts are
unknown this is a message to the
brothers or stayed behind and we had
come from Cardiff also entered in 20-30
well known for appearing in this Islamic
state propaganda videos he was later
killed just dealing with this huge
amount of data is staggering the time
consuming there is simply so much it
came from this man a free syrian army
convert to Islamic state Abu Hamed he
calls himself disillusioned with the
Islamic state leadership its takeover by
bath his party commanders from Iraq and
a total collapse in the Islamic rules he
supported he decided to quit out of the
club on the nurse indeed or mother Maud
don't leave don't leave given your daily
slur Murphy or she meet our vocal Cheryl
Aslam ever done other day bade analyst
low I met him in a secret location in
San Onofre in Turkey where he finds
refuge with his Turkish Arab family he
makes two points first that is is
finished in Syria and second that
they're working hand in hand with the
Syrian government is this information so
important that it could actually
destroyed us charla is what might be
that's what I first thought the more I
keep and if you were to tell someone how
to use it what would you tell hey Milo
modest quality Achilles quality in rats
mm nom yeah he once a hundred solemnly
nurse and stole the dash Nestle if Ellen
the stinger she that stole the dash move
the tilde milanesa shanty ouch three of
the jihad jihad humbly the Islamic state
files reveal a very sophisticated system
of analysis recruit would enter through
a series of points across the Turkish
border joining Islamic state wasn't a
case of just turning up the would-be
jihadists had to give an awful lot of
their personal information away
including their real names which they
always
changed telephone numbers if they had
them where they're from and crucially
who sponsored them and brought them into
the organization that that information
was top secret and was entrusted to the
head of internal security for amex Tate
and he put them on memory sticks the
information on this could bring down the
entire network not just in Iraq and
Syria but across the world because
wherever they came from if they joined
up it's on here our analysis of the
files reveal that jihadists have made
their way to Syria from at least 51
nations across the globe many of course
have now returned home from the attacks
in Tunisia through to the batter clan
theater massacre in Paris it's clear
that the Islamic state is attempting to
move its base of operations abroad the
security services are right now warning
of more high-profile attacks these files
are simply the best intelligence that's
ever existed about Islamic state
certainly the best they could hope for